nous repartons à kiev où l'on retrouve
tout de suite clovis casali notre envoyé
spécial clovis quelle est la situation
sur le terrain dans la capitale
ukrainienne
eh bien on entend encore des détonations
des coups de feu et il semblerait que
dans le quartier de la gare ici à kiev
et bien les forces du chrétienne soit
sur le qui vive il y aurait eu des tirs
nourris toute cette nuit on a aussi vu
des tirs de roquettes ici à kiev et il y
a eu bien sûr ces raids aériens russes
incessants elle la nuit qui ont touché
notamment à 30 km de la capitale un
dépôt pétrolier un entrepôt qui stockent
de l'essence vous pouvez imaginer les
fumées toxiques qui s'en sont dégagées
on ne les a pas encore ressenti ici à
kiev dans le centre-ville ça dépend bien
sûr du vent une situation tendue encore
des explosions encore à des combats et
les ukrainiens les autorités
ukrainiennes
communique de leur côté sur les
prisonniers par exemple qu'ils ont fait
côté russe c'est aux autorités
ukrainiennes déclare qu'il qu'ils ont au
moins capturé deux cents prisonniers
russes et qu'ils ont détruit plus de 140
chars qu'ils ont détruit plus de 700
véhicules blindés à des chiffres bien
sûr à prendre avec des précautions
puisque ce sont des chiffres des médias
ukrainiens mais il semblerait que les
ukrainiens tiennent bon ici à kiev
repousse les arbres les avancées russe
une situation toujours bien évidemment
très tendu interdit que nous sommes en
plein couvre-feu ce jusqu'à lundi
interdiction pour quiconque de sortir à
moins d'être un combattant ukrainiens ou
d où des soldats d'ukrainiens pourquoi
très clairement et bien les ukrainiens
ont peur de ce qu'ils appellent ces
saboteurs russe ces agents russes qui
pourraient qui pourrait être infiltrée
au sol qui pourraient être déguisé par
exemple en policiers ukrainiens ils en
ont arrêtés ils en ont neutralisé
certains et les consignes sont très
clairs tout civil qui se trouvera dont
les rues de kiev pendant son coût ce
couvre-feu pour être considéré comme un
ennemi potentiel et pourra être
l'objet de tirs le président ukrainien
volodimir zelensky est très présent dans
les vidéos sur internet où se
trouve-t-il actuellement lui et ses
conseillers
en tout cas le président ukrainien
difficile de dire exactement où il se
trouve il semblerait qu'il soit ici à
kiev il communique énormément l'ancien
comédien devenu à président devenu qui
s'est imposée véritablement en chef de
guerre aux commandes il publie
régulièrement des vidéos des appels à la
nation pour l'unité du peuple pour
appelé les ukrainiens à prendre les
armes lui et le reste du gouvernement
restent bien évidemment aux manettes et
le maire de la ville l'ancien boxeur
vitali klitschko lui aussi il est même
au front avec des hommes à combattre
l'envahisseur russe lui aussi en appelle
à la communauté internationale pour
venir en aide aux ukrainiens eux qui
sont face à l'imposante armées russes
est ce que vous savez clovis si les
jeunes continuent de s'enrôler s'ils
sont prêts à se battre
quartier par quartier maison par maison
selon les témoignages et bien oui les
ukrainiens sont fortement mobilisés les
hommes de tout âge jusqu'à 60 ans le et
les femmes d'ailleurs près par des
cocktails molotov pour pour attaquer les
russes et ces jeunes volontaires se sont
mobilisés nombreux ici à kiev ils sont
allés dans les armureries ils sont aussi
allés dans les commissariats et dans les
différents dépôts où on distribue des
armes le gouvernement ukrainien a besoin
d'hommes a besoin de combattants qu'ils
soient aguerris ou non ils distribuent
des armes pour qu'ils puissent justement
repousser l'assaillant russes mais aussi
pour que ces gens puissent défendre leur
maison pour qu'ils soient postés dans
différents quartiers au cas où des
agents russes en reconnaissance par
exemple soit sur le terrain et aussi
bien sûr pour contrer à l'avancée des
chars russes et c'est le cas aux
alentours aux abords de kiev dans les
banlieues de nombreuses vidéos sorte où
on voit justement à ces civils si vous
voulez qu'ils sont devenus combattants
par la force des choses c'est ukrainien
qu'ils essayent d'empêcher l'avancée des
russes et pour l'instant ils y arrivent
merci beaucoup clovis casali merci à
vous pour votre analyse est la situation
à kiev